why not 7 A.M I don't know bro uh I got
that name from Wiz actually that's a
good name yeah bro we were just in the
studio one day or one night one day or
whatever the hell you call it it was
actually six a.m I kept repeating it in
this song over and over again he was
just like bro as soon as I walked out
the booth he's like bro you're six a.m
right I just I I ran with it since then
yeah so before you were six a.m yeah you
were in a group called osbs I still am
in a group called osps we're just you
know
doing your own taking a little shout to
fizzy break for a little bit hell yeah
shout out feeding my brother so osbs
obviously you guys have some dope
records you went on tour with uh was it
Doug uh a gun Ghana and and whiz yeah
um isn't gonna
what and and the music you guys were
making was a lot more different than the
music you're currently making oh for
sure yeah
I felt like the music that we were
making was uh
it was like
Dope music you know what I mean but I
think the I think that
the main thing between then and now is
just me like not knowing myself as an
artist I'm not like trying to like just
like make a song I'm just making songs
that I like you know I mean like I'm
making songs more organic yeah it's
geared towards me I'm not really trying
to be like I'm not I'm not I don't
really I don't want to talk about the
same things yeah yeah you know how it is
when you when you when you first start
out you know what I mean like I was kind
of trying to like
find myself and then like try to find
who I was as an artist after that you
know what I mean right so like it kind
of took a while for me to be like okay I
don't want to talk about cars I don't
want to talk about
um money like that I want to talk about
hidden licks and sliding just like
I don't know it just wasn't like
it
wasn't
it wasn't the same for me after a while
right I think we are on on tour and like
Denver or something honestly and I took
[ __ ] DMT
and like once I took that
DNT it was like a whole switch like and
my whole body just changed like
instantly and I just like saw things
way differently like almost instantly
but it was [ __ ] crazy well DMT is a
serious uh psychedelic oh yeah it's like
so you smoke Aaron Rodgers drug yeah did
you smoke it yeah I did Freebase uh no
we smoked it out of a [ __ ] Apple
actually you smoke DMT out of an apple
yeah we smoked DMT out of an apple it
was like it was hella weird I can't
imagine that's the best way to smoke it
no I don't think it is but like uh I
don't know how to even like
it's like it's like a a white kind of
like it's like substance which I don't
[ __ ] with you know I mean yeah it looks
like some and then the way you're
actually supposed to smoke it is you're
supposed to freebase it yeah that's I'm
not with that [ __ ] you know I mean
that's how you're supposed to really oh
I know but you're like give me the Apple
yeah that's that's chill so
basically what we did is put like weed
on the bottom and put like a layer of
like DNT in the middle like a little
like a hamburger you know what I mean
then you put like a layer of of weed on
top so you use the weed on top to like
burn through to the DMT so you're not
actually going to touch the fire to like
the the yeah it sounds like tea you know
I mean yeah it sounds like you should
try to smoke DMT again no so it's
crackhead away well I did like 80 times
that's why I'm like this now you know
what I mean so like have you smoked it
the right way yet yes I have so you have
no that's not the right way I wouldn't
consider that the right way what do you
think is the right way
uh I think out of a a wood pipe is the
correct way to to do it from what I've
heard I've never heard anybody even
talking about like freebasing freebasing
anything until you right now we have
Freebase of DMT man you get the [ __ ]
I'm not a big you're not a tour
you're supposed to smoke it out of a
crack pipe get the [ __ ] out of here bro
for sure
Kev where did you hear this from
everybody in my entire life that does it
they smoke it out of a crack pipe
because it's the most purest way to hit
it
I'm being serious I don't know about
that bro honestly you have like the
actual toad sweat or whatever from the
[ __ ] frog right and it's like yeah
yeah I don't know about that yeah so
that [ __ ] you're supposed to actually
I've never smoked that I've only smoked
like the like the what's it called a
tree bark so tree bark what's the
craziest thing you've seen on a DMT trip
oh instantly bro like the first time I I
did DMT it was me
fizzy and my cousin and then my cousin
did it first and he just like laid back
quietly and he just got absolutely quiet
and he went away for about 20 minutes or
so right no it's like two three minutes
and I'm like bro what the [ __ ] and he's
like
shh so me and uh feezy are both like
what the [ __ ] is going on and he like
comes out of it after like two or three
minutes and just like sits up and
there's tears coming down his face like
literally like there's just like two
little yeah two little tears just
dripping down the side of his face and
he's like bro like you don't understand
he's like he's like the aliens are here
and it's okay and I'm like what the [ __ ]
so you're like give me something no
instantly I'm like all right let me try
that so I hit it and honestly bro like
the whole room just got like quiet like
the whole room got quiet and I was still
100 present and like mentally in the in
the moment like I knew I had just hit
DMT right there was no high involved
like change whatsoever but like
it's like a unlocked and hold uh another
dimension I was still completely
sobering in my mind and able to
understand exactly what was going on
there was basically just like little
[ __ ] aliens popping out from behind
like
random ass shapes being like like we're
here but don't don't tell anybody type
[ __ ] I know this sounds absolutely
insane but it actually doesn't because I
mean if you I I mean it doesn't sound
that crazy it's pretty intense bro so
like is that the most intense though
because I've heard people like go away
[ __ ] no dude for 20 minutes 10 things in
the world is uh
I'm Salvia dude I mean no I mean like
for you it was at the most intense
experience you had on DMT oh yeah but
it's nothing compared to to salvio
whatsoever what the [ __ ] is that bro are
you serious right now
is salvia legal it's legal they they
sell that [ __ ] smoke shop it's like
spice dude it's the strongest [ __ ]
thing I've it's the worst possible
experience you can ever have bro like
I was 18 years old my first week of
college
uh I was on my homies like bunk bed he
had like a bunk bed in this room there
was like a bunk for him like his like
a dog slept on top so right some [ __ ]
like that so then the dog's on top of
the bed and I [ __ ] hit this [ __ ] and
I'm looking into like a mirror in his
room
whole room turns into to uh to as soon
as I exhale the whole room turned into
like mirrors like a million of them what
I'm [ __ ] stuck in this room locked in
it's like an over
overwhelming like Dread [ __ ] feeling
and I stand up as fast as I can to try
to escape and all of a sudden I just
feel something warm like dripping down
my head bro and I'm like what the [ __ ] I
snapped at it after like two minutes and
my homie's like bro what the [ __ ] you
okay you okay I look I look bro and
there's [ __ ] like blood dripping down
from my eyebrow onto my head from where
I split my [ __ ] head open on the bus
from the from the Salvia dude some [ __ ]
I bought from like a smoke shop like 20
bucks Jesus Christ oh my God worse than
worst worse than DMT like change your
life for the positive it did honestly
bro you remember how it was before you
know right you know me bro I was I was a
little uh
I was a little harsh bro I was a little
like you're definitely on your ignorant
gangster [ __ ] yeah a little bit bro and
I feel like the
DMT and just like life experience like
having my kid and [ __ ] kind of like took
me to a whole different place where I
was like aware of the energy I'm putting
into the world and aware of the energy
I'm putting into my music you know I
mean and like I don't I don't really
want to influence people to be out here
and living in the way they're not
supposed to be you know what I mean and
like affect the music that I make now
kind of either like teaches people to
deal with like certain things that
they're like right going through helps
people like understand certain like
emotions or feelings that they might be
having and it just kind of puts me in a
different place like karmically you know
what I mean like for sure I feel like
I'm such a [ __ ] like a drain on the
energy of the world which I feel like a
lot of of music that I even had to stop
listening to like that just because the
[ __ ] like negative it's a lot of
nativity too bro like it's like if you
listen to something over and over again
in your subconsciously it sticks
subconsciously that [ __ ] is all in your
head bro like even whether you recognize
it or not it's just not for me no more
bro